We talked about different,
you know,
political outcomes and you know,
over the long run,
uh,
Great Britain becomes a,
remains a constitutional monarchy.
And even in the 19th century when Victoria,
I had great,
uh,
great prestige,
um,
she did not have great power,
uh,
in the Netherlands,
also resisted absolutism and the Dutch republic,
uh,
remained the Dutch republic,
although for reasons that we'll see later,
uh,
the Dutch republic a ceases to be a great power I in the 18th century.
So I given the very different route that Prussia and Austria and Russia and
Sweden and France went,
uh,
with,
a centralization of absolute rule.
Why did it work out so differently for a England slash Britain,
uh,
and,
and the Netherlands.
So we just want to,
again,
this is a,
the second and last of these sort of holding pattern lectures.
This parallels exactly what you're reading,
uh,
because again,
until we get our class set and all that,
and then a very different kind of lecture starting on Wednesday,
Wednesday or Monday,
next Monday.
Um,
so,
but let's just think a lot about what these places had in common and what this
tells you about,
uh,
about social structure and political outcomes in early modern Europe.
And of course,
the consequences are enormous,
uh,
for other kinds of outcomes.
Let me give you an example.
Uh,
Germany,
uh,
is not unified until 1871.
Uh,
ironically a unification proclaimed in the,
in the hall of Mirrors,
uh,
at the Chateau Versailles,
which we'll visit for a few seconds,
uh,
later on.
Uh,
and the fact that Germany,
German unification was achieved by pressure and that pressure was dominated by
nobles who were called [inaudible].
You'll come to them later,
uh,
and by an army,
which in which the state basically was an appendage of the army,
had rather enormous consequences for,
for Europe,
uh,
in the late 19th and above all in the,
in the 20th century.
Uh,
so in the 1960 to 1970s,
people paid a lot more attention to social structure,
uh,
and,
you know,
sort of class analysis.
But,
but you know,
when you look at Britain,
uh,
experience of Britain and,
the Dutch republic,
they do share things that,
that,
uh,
in a way determine the kind of of political economy,
that they would have.
So what,
you know,
what are some of these things that I've written up on the board,
uh,
there,
but let's just start a not necessarily a,
well,
I guess,
uh,
yeah,
I guess in the,
in that order and just kind of think aloud.
And then when I'm going to do the last 20 or 25 minutes is talk about the Dutch
republic.
And so you could skip that part in the reading,
which isn't very long.
And again,
illustrate,
uh,
with some paintings that you,
for what you're not responsible,
but just to make the points I want to make about the nature of the Dutch
republic in which we'll see,
you'll see in ways in which it was very similar to England slash Great Britain
and very different,
uh,
in terms of,
of,
uh,
of France.
Uh,
so first of all,
um,
it's not a coincidence that in both England and in the Dutch republic,
you had,
uh,
along with northern Italy,
the city states in northern Italy,
you had the largest percentage of the,
uh,
of,
of middle class population that you could find in Europe of that,
in if the,
if the middleclass in,
in,
in Russia,
I,
which I'll talk about on Monday,
was just absolutely minuscule.
Uh,
the,
the middleclass was extremely small in,
in Prussia.
A pressure did not include,
you know,
the Hanseatic League cities such as,
uh,
it's a Braman and,
and,
and humble and,
and the others.
Uh,
so you have in,
in the Netherlands and,
uh,
in England and astonishingly large,
middleclass morever.
Moreover,
uh,
in,
in the case of England,
uh,
there was a tremendous fluidity between elites.
A,
that's a percentage of the population who was noble,
uh,
who had noble titles,
was extremely small.
Uh,
uh,
privilege,
came from wealth and wealth was,
uh,
stem from the land yet because of the rapid and dramatic expansion of the
English role in the global economy,
uh,
you had lots of very wealthy landlord or landlord's property owners investing in
commerce.
Uh,
whereas in a,
in Spain,
uh,
and in,
in France and in Prussia,
in particularly,
it was,
seemed to be sort of,
uh,
slumming,
for,
uh,
nobles to participate in commerce.
Now that,
you know,
Marxist analysis has given us this,
this is all too rigid,
uh,
a picture of the nobility sort of letting their nails grow long.
And,
and,
uh,
they are nobles because they do nothing.
That was part of it.
Certainly there were nobles and France and,
uh,
who bought up vineyards in,
in,
uh,
around Boldo or they're nobles or into lose hoo,
hoo around to lose who have great,
uh,
invest in commercial agriculture.
But yet the fact remains that it's really in England,
uh,
that you have this tremendous fluidity between within the elite,
and that,
uh,
you know,
basically commercial money talks,
uh,
as much as propertied monied talks,
um,
London,
I already by the late 16th century one,
sixth of all the people,
I think this is a Tony Wrigley,
a Ea Wrigley who pointed this out long time ago.
One sixth of all the people in England went to London frequently,
frequently,
well,
whereas this would,
this would because of London was absolutely gigantic,
has a city,
the only cities in Europe that were comparable and they were smaller,
where Naples,
extraordinarily poor a city and,
and,
uh,
Constantinople,
Istanbul.
Uh,
and of course in Japan,
Eto,
which would become,
uh,
known as Tokyo.
And so the percentage of the English population that would have considered
themselves to be,
you know,
middleclass is extraordinarily large.
Now,
the same is even more true in the Netherlands.
Uh,
their work to be sure nobles in the Netherlands are,
they tend to deliver in the eastern part and rural,
uh,
Netherlands,
and in the south.
Uh,
but their lives and their interests were far,
far away from the day from that economic,
uh,
large machine,
which was Amsterdam and Amsterdam is dominated by the middle classes.
Now the middleclass want political rights.
They want prerogatives.
They want their privileges for themselves.
Uh,
and uh,
certainly,
uh,
it,
it is fair to,
to,
to argue that that non titled People in England,
uh,
we're at the forefront of the victorious,
um,
role in the civil war of that parliament,
uh,
played now,
in,
in the city states of,
of,
of Venice and,
and of,
uh,
which was a major trading city already on the decline.
And in Florence and in Milan and in Turin and places like that,
uh,
you,
you find something very comparable,
but,
but these are the,
Italy is not United until the 1860s.
Uh,
so northern Italy has a,
uh,
has a,
a large percentage of the population who are,
are,
are middle class.
But,
but in talking about the political outcomes of,
of states,
uh,
that's,
it doesn't really fit into our analysis here.
Um,
now,
part of that is that along with northern Italy,
uh,
the Netherlands and,
and,
and England slash Great Britain have,
uh,
by far the most urbanized population,
in,
uh,
in Europe,
that if you go into Serbia,
for example,
what now is Serbia.
I mean,
they're basically,
it was Belgrade,
which was a small place.
Uh,
Poland had a very lively,
important cities,
uh,
Warsaw and Krakow,
and some of Gdansk as well.
Uh,
uh,
so you can't just say,
well,
in eastern Europe there weren't cities,
but there isn't any place,
uh,
including France,
that had a remotely as high as percentage of the population living in cities,
uh,
as,
England,
uh,
and,
and the Netherlands.
And one of the great shifts in English history,
English,
British history that you,
that you,
you know,
become aware,
uh,
is the shift of economic dynamism in England,
a way from the south to the north.
Uh,
in the time we're starting this course in the 17th century,
besides London,
which is this gigantic place,
uh,
the biggest cities in England where we're at Norwich and Exeter and then York,
in the north.
And of course with a large scale industrialization,
which begins I in the middle of the 18th century,
you,
you'll see this dramatic shift up to the north.
And then of course,
Manchester,
which was a small town,
becomes this,
uh,
enormous city in Liverpool becomes ever more important.
Um,
but you know,
cities that are or were in the middle class lives and,
and bourgeois,
you know,
and Burgers,
as I said last time come from,
you know,
these are urban residents who,
who,
who were losing their privileges on the continent to big time absolute states.
Uh,
and,
uh,
they will defend quite vociferously their privileges as,
as the town's people against a pretentions absolutist pretentions of,
of,
of nobles in the,
in the case of,
of the Netherlands.
And also to an extent in England as well.
So they share those things in common,
which is not to say that a country like France wasn't a with an urbanized,
because France is Paris is already enormous,
or 500,000 people about it.
The time of the French revolution,
I,
there's so many people you can't count because they own nothing.
And also we don't have really accurate censuses until the 19th century.
The first accurate census I think is in Copenhagen,
uh,
in the end of the,
of the 18th century.
And most censuses were taken by the way,
as a way of counting heads,
uh,
the number of people who had to be fed at the time of a siege.
So we were,
we're kind of guessing on,
on,
on these population figures.
Uh,
but,
uh,
um,
the fact remains that that the Netherlands and England,
Britain,
uh,
share,
this and this,
this is important in terms of,
of a political outcomes and also important in,
in the case of England,
Britain,
uh,
in,
what we've come to call the industrial revolution,
which I will talk about,
uh,
talk about at another time.
Um,
secondly,
as I tried to suggest the other day,
uh,
that,
you know,
these places Resu,
uh,
they,
they resist absolutism,
uh,
that the English civil war,
it's,
it's kind of a generalization to,
uh,
to make that,
to,
to underline that too much,
but,
but nonetheless,
the,
uh,
people,
living in,
uh,
in England in the 1640s,
saw that there was a real threat to,
uh,
the idea of the free born Englishman,
that was coming from,
uh,
from the trampling of,
of,
of long assumed rights since at least the 13th century,
at least in the imagination,
uh,
of,
of people,
uh,
by,
by kings who wanted to dispense with,
with the rights of parliament and run things as,
uh,
as they wanted to.
Um,
and in the case of,
of the Netherlands,
it's the same thing.
I mean the,
the,
uh,
there isn't anything as dramatic as the English civil war,
but the important kind of outcome is that in the end,
this decentralized federalist structure,
which I described in the book and we'll talk a little bit about in a while,
uh,
is victorious over the pretensions of a potential dynastic ruling house that is
the Orange House,
the house of Orange,
uh,
who would want it to make the chief Dutch official,
it was called the stockholder holder.
You can you read that in,
uh,
in the book and wanted to turn that person into kind of a sundering,
semi absolutist monarch.
And that doesn't work as well.
Uh,
and when you think of the origins of the Netherlands,
the origins of the Netherlands comes from a civil war,
a war or a war of independence against the Spanish absolute to state.
That begins in when 1572 and goes on and off all the time until Dutch
independence.
It's a recognized,
it was a fet to complete for a long time,
but until the Dutch independence was recognized in 1648 at the Treaty of
Westphalia.
So for the Dutch,
when they imagine,
you know,
scary things,
a scary thing as an army sent by,
uh,
sent by,
the King of Spain,
uh,
to extract more taxes from the wealthiest of all the Spanish pro,
provinces that is the Netherlands rich because of commerce.
And as we'll see in a minute,
to try to force people to remain Catholics at a time when the vast majority of
the Dutch population had converted to Calvinism.
And so the,
in the,
the,
those people who believed in the Dutch republic,
which is the vast majority of the people,
uh,
just as people,
the majority of the population of England who held to the rights of parliament,
they have this sort of scary scenario of their rights being violated,
trampled upon,
destroyed,
eliminated,
or eradicated by big time absolute rulers.
And the other scary thing for the Dutch is of course,
if the big guy down south,
uh,
because,
Louis,
the 14th would love to control all of,
of,
of the Netherlands and his invasions w at one time or turned by back when they
literally opened the dikes.
And flood the French armies back.
And so,
you know,
in,
in the,
the,
the mental construction of the Dutch and the English both involves one thing
they don't want to be,
and that is to lose their progressives,
the rights to an absolute state.
And in both cases,
this becomes part of their self identity.
That's an essential part is my good friend Linda colony and used to teach here
and sadly is no,
not here anymore.
She's at Princeton,
uh,
that she made in her argument,
made an argument in her very successful book called Britain's the construction
of British identity.
Uh,
and I will argue later in the course in 1848,
it has to get reinvented again by imagining and the other who is perceived as
sneaky and dangerous.
And of course,
in that case is the French,
but also point of view of the British,
the Irish who were conceived of this perceived,
of as being capable because of their quest for Macron and be trampled by the,
by the English definitely by English Protestants,
ah,
of hooking up with,
uh,
with France,
which they tried to do in 1798,
uh,
or in the world war one with Germany.
Uh,
because there were some attempts of the Germans to,
to a stoke up Irish independence movements.
So again,
the only point here is that they see themselves as abs anti absolute test,
and this helps them create this,
this sense of identity,
which helps determine their political,
uh,
their political origins.
And you'll find nothing comparable in,
in Russia,
obviously,
which we'll come back and talk about.
We're in Prussia,
uh,
or in France,
you can talk about the origins of French nationalism in the middle of the,
of the 18th century,
but it's very closely tied to this dynasty at least until they lop off the guy's
head,
you know,
in 1793.
Uh,
so,
okay.
So that's sort of that,
that point.
Um,
cern is
decentralization,
uh,
is that both of these states are decentralized states.
The British don't have a police force until one 18,
27 or 29.
I can't remember which,
when Robert Peale creates an London police force,
which they call the bobbies after,
you know,
like Robert,
Bob,
Bobby's,
uh,
and people didn't want that.
They didn't want a large standing army.
What are the identified large standing armies with?
They always had to have a lord standing navy for obvious reasons,
but they identified large standing armies with France or with,
uh,
the Spain of Phillip the second or with pressure or with Russia.
And so it didn't mean that the English state wasn't efficient in collecting
taxes cause they were more efficient than the French were in collecting taxes.
But it does mean that,
that this decentralization is an essential part of who they thought they were.
Uh,
that the sheriff,
the local sheriff,
you know,
he'll,
he'll call up the guys and the restore order when,
uh,
when there's trouble,
but there's this real kind of a,
of fear that,
that the standing lord standing armies are,
uh,
it could ultimately compromise the rights of free born Englishman.
And that's in a way that they would have put it in the case of the Netherlands,
which I'll come back to in a while.
You have these provinces that,
that although Amsterdam though,
you know,
Holland,
which is the province of Amsterdam,
is by far the most important of the,
of the pro,
uh,
and most prosperous of,
of the,
of the Dutch,
uh,
provinces such as that we often miss call the Netherlands Holland when in fact
Holland is just one of the,
uh,
one of the provinces is if you call it the United States in New York or
California,
because those are the two most powerful states in,
uh,
in the United States.
Uh,
but the sort of decentralized federalist structure is part of who they thought
they were and who they continue to think they are.
Um,
and this is very different than uh,
uh,
then,
then these absolute kings who can send out their,
their,
uh,
their armies can run by their minions to squish whomever they want.
Grapes,
whenever there's trouble.
And we can exaggerate the power of Phillip.
I mean,
of a Peter,
the grade became this vast empire that's expanding south and already expanding
towards Siberia and such just in places.
It took a long time to get the,
get the,
the,
the guys there.
But when they got there,
there was hell to pay a very,
very different than this,
this federalist structure of a decentralized structure of a,
of both of these countries.
And the political outcome is to,
is different.
Now,
you can also make that argument.
We don't,
this isn't the course to do that,
but you can make that argument about the United States and the,
of course,
the evolution of the United States when they,
when they,
uh,
because of the,
of the,
the local,
a prestige of local leaders and the decentralized notion that nature of the
colonies already at the time of the war of independence,
which we're going to have a strong,
a strong,
a role in the political outcome for better,
for worse,
uh,
in this country where you have this or a Wacko political systems to,
there's still exist because of,
you know,
people screaming states rights and all that.
But that's,
that's another,
that's another subject.
Um,
okay.
Fourth,
you know,
antiques,
Catholicism,
uh,
in both cases,
why,
uh,
well,
because these are,
these are major,
major countries in,
in,
in the reformation,
uh,
that the,
you know,
the English reformation,
which would be getting begins with Henry Henry the eighth,
you know,
uh,
wanting to divorce is very,
and kill his various wives.
Uh,
you know,
along the way,
I still had an awful lot to do with resistance to the power of Rome.
Uh,
and the,
the power of,
of the Catholic Church as an institution in the case of the Netherlands,
uh,
anti Catholicism is endemic.
Why?
Because it's identified with,
with the Spanish empire,
with Spain,
which not only wanting to extract taxes and other revenue from its most
prosperous province.
I been wanted to force people,
uh,
to,
remain Catholic.
And when they send this guy called the Duke of Alba Up to,
uh,
up to the Netherlands,
I mean,
he,
you know,
Burns people to the steak and all this kind of stuff.
Uh,
and so,
uh,
and the Association of,
of Catholicism as the dominant religion in,
uh,
in both of the,
the enemy countries that is France and,
uh,
um,
and Spain,
uh,
is extremely important.
Now,
this is not to say that the Dutch don't fight the English too because they do
their various wars over,
over,
you know,
control of the seas.
But nonetheless,
in,
uh,
in the imagination of both of these are in the,
in the metal,
uh,
measuring antibody in the mental sort of construction of these,
of these two countries.
What we are not that is Catholic,
uh,
helps,
helps define their identity.
Of course,
a particular problem of Ireland or challenge of Ireland as I suggested earlier.
It has an awful lot to do with that and the reinvention in the 19th century of
British identity.
We also have a lot to do with fear of the Irish,
you know,
the enemy within as they were perceived.
But more about that.
I'll talk about that a lot a lot and try to explain why there was no revolution
in England,
uh,
in 18,
in 1848.
And then of course,
of,
uh,
in the course of,
of,
of Britain,
it's even clearer because the French is,
is,
uh,
you know,
this Niki French,
uh,
and,
and from the British,
the French point of view with the perfidious Albion already there.
And if you know,
you can go all the way,
uh,
you know,
up to the origins of World War One,
uh,
to see,
I mean when the British to get into world war one is because of the violation
of,
uh,
of Belgian neutrality by the Germans because the idea of having another enemy,
you've already got the French across the channel and it's not that big a
channel.
You could swim across it.
Uh,
I couldn't,
but,
and you couldn't either,
but as people have and do it all the time.
But if you've got the Germans in Austan eating mood fleet,
uh,
you know,
eating mussels with French fries and you've already got the French there,
this is unthinkable.
So they go,
they go,
they go to order,
finally are going to go to war.
Um,
so you know,
this,
I don't want to exaggerate this too much,
but the largest riots in,
in Britain in the 18th century are not the riots for political reform at all.
There are the anti-catholic riots called the Gordon riots,
which take care take place in London.
So Anti Catholicism,
you know,
is very much strongly entrenched in,
in,
uh,
in British,
in the British sense of,
of who they were.
Um,
uh,
then we'll antifa French.
We already went over.
There we go.
So I mean,
those two are already linked along with absolute TISM and,
uh,
resist anti absolutism,
and Anti Catholicism.
Uh,
and then last,
you know,
there's a,
and this sort of,
these,
all of these things are linked.
I mean,
you could do these one of these little boxes they do in sociology or political
science and have these arrows running all over the place and,
and,
and you can make it there,
but,
but what,
who are the biggest trading powers,
uh,
in,
in Europe,
uh,
we forget about the,
about the enormous trading vitality of Asia,
even at the Ysi vitality and land vitality at the same time.
But our,
without any question,
by this point,
with the decline of the Spanish empire,
which begins before this course,
uh,
are the Dutch and the English.
And so what this does is it increases,
you know,
the role of this commercial,
uh,
middle class and increases the role of cities,
particularly port cities,
of which Amsterdam is,
uh,
and it increases their,
the,
the role of these economic elites,
or they're concerned with maintaining their privileges against threats to their
privileges and to their prosperity no matter where they come from.
So you could just have to amuse yourself,
not for any kind of punitive,
think about the exam exercise,
but to be funded.
So take these categories and thinking about these other countries,
uh,
particularly those were absolute states,
other large important states in Europe,
and see to what extent you have these factors there.
Prussia,
I already said fresher.
You've got your big,
big noble,
you've got all these guys with dueling star,
a scars and,
and,
uh,
for them to be indulging in commerce.
It's just sort of,
you know,
crass and,
and not terribly manly and all of this business.
Uh,
and you've got you,
you've got your,
your flute playing King of at Frederick the grade who could be awful,
you know,
could lash out.
And you know,
Voltaire,
I went and hung out with Frederick the great,
and after a while he said,
let me Outta here.
Uh,
uh,
but you've got,
you've got Berlin,
which was a very important town,
but it's a very important town,
very important city because it's got this huge garrison and has got factories
turning out military uniforms.
Uh,
and it's got to,
it's got Potsdam,
palace and all of this.
Uh,
so it's not at all the same thing as Amsterdam or London or any of the other
trading cities.
Uh,
around,
uh,
with the case of,
of,
uh,
Russia is even easier.
You've got a practically nonexistent and middle class.
You've got all sorts of nobles and they do,
are involved in,
you know,
in commerce.
Some of them are,
but mostly what they do is they serve the state.
They're called a service nobility.
They're not serving the cities.
They're not serving,
you know,
commerce.
What they're doing is they're serving the state.
They're serving this huge,
you know,
lumbering.
A strange guy,
uh,
Peter,
the great,
and then you could take other places like Italy and,
and,
you know,
smaller,
smaller cities,
but you don't yet have these big state structures.
So if you're looking back,
say from the end of the 19th century,
it's kind of,
it's not easy to see,
but you can see these,
these,
you know,
you don't ever think that history runs on railroad tracks and,
and all you need is the timetable to show when modernization shows up.
That's almost ludicrous.
A word really.
And contemporary a,
a social science,
uh,
or Orthodox Marxists where you just had to say,
well,
eventually the proletariat will rise up cause the bourgeoise he did this,
uh,
before.
But yet when you look back from the 19th century,
these factors do count and explaining how countries,
uh,
turn out to be the way they are.
And when you're trying to look at the origins of war,
a one,
I mean,
it mattered that,
that,
uh,
Germany is run by this kind of Madcap Doofus,
you know,
Wilhelm the second who was intellectually lazy and,
and,
uh,
I like to,
you know,
break a bottles of Riesling over a,
a bright,
shiny battleships and,
and didn't concentrate on things very long and sends off a,
you know,
provocative telegrams here and there to make everybody mad.
I mean that it has a long run outcome,
which,
you know,
Costa the lives of millions of people.
But,
but,
uh,
so anyway,
here we go.
I mean,
but it's just,
it's kind of fun to think about that.
So that's what we were doing.
We were thinking about that.
Now,
now let's,
let's,
let's dim the lights.
Here we go.
How do we dim the lights?
I can't remember how he dimmed the lights.
Is that what you do?
Aw,
okay,
well that's good.
Okay.
Oh no,
that's not good here.
We got to get further down than that.
Hey.
Oh,
all right,
so electric.
Okay.
Now let's,
I'm paralleling what,
what,
uh,
you been been reading?
Let's,
how over.
Thanks.
Let's look a little bit at the Dutch republic because people talk about England
and Britain all the time.
And,
uh,
so let me,
talk about the Dutch republic.
And this will kind of bring some of these factors together along with the idea
of what people thought they were,
what is their identity?
And here again,
we'll look at some paintings and you're not responsible for these paintings,
but we'll kind of illustrate ways in which the duck Dutch republic and their
social structure and what they emphasized and who they thought they were was
very different than,
for example,
La Bella.
False.
Um,
so,
uh,
here we have Amsterdam.
Uh,
and,
and so Amsterdam,
you know,
uh,
it,
it grows dramatically because of this global trade in,
uh,
in,
in the 17th century.
And,
uh,
that was 16,
13.
I made this,
this is all a bunch of jumble,
but,
but this is,
you know,
16 a 40 or something like that
later.
Um,
but what you have are these canals.
And many of you are,
some of you have had the good fortune to go to.
One of yours was wonderful cities and,
and you know,
the canals were used to transport goods and thus the city structure itself,
the way the city was built or with houses along the canals reflect the economic
primacy of global trade.
I mean,
at this time,
the doctor sending herring,
these long sort of flat boats,
herring ships are going all the way to Newfoundland,
uh,
you know,
in the 17th century in Iceland,
freezing off the coast of Iceland.
And they control and dominate the,
the Baltic trade in herring is an important part of that cause.
Hearing we'll keep once it's salted and all that.
So the city of Amsterdam,
Amsterdam grows up not only as part of the struggle,
Victoria struggle against,
uh,
the Spanish,
a Spanish armies.
There's a wonderful book by my,
uh,
a former,
colleague Jeffrey Parker.
I called the Spanish road,
was talked about how difficult it was for the Spa Spanish to get troops all the
way to the,
to,
uh,
the Netherlands.
I mean,
they had to go from it from Italy because much of Italy was controlled by Spain
through the Alps all the way up along the Rhine and finally get into,
uh,
get into,
the Dutch republic.
And it was a,
it was a losing battle.
But,
you know,
Amsterdam reflects this kind of primacy of,
of,
of the global economy,
uh,
because it's such an important trading power.
Uh,
but also this sort of federalist decentralized aspect that I've tried to,
uh,
tried to describe,
this is the,
you know,
the ship.
This is the ship yard behind,
in fact,
this building and that behind,
it's still there.
I did it when I go to Amsterdam,
not frequently,
but I've been there for,
you know,
10 or 12 times or something.
I did a field trip there.
I mean,
we took a,
you know,
all these alumni around to look at it,
look at all this stuff,
and that was mildly fun.
Um,
but the,
the what,
what the,
what the Dutch did,
I mean the,
the Netherlands is,
is extraordinarily small country.
Um,
and it's the most populated country in Europe,
then it per square kilometer and is now,
uh,
at once.
And so what they tried to,
what they have to do in order to,
you know,
in order to feed the population,
you have to have more land now,
how you're going to get more land,
when are they credible things.
If you're driving,
say from growing again,
and you're going to go all the way down to Amsterdam when you drive along the
coast,
you know,
you're driving along this,
this sort of road,
this,
that's out in the sea.
And,
and all the land between the water on both be on the left side of you and a
long,
long way has been reclaimed from the sea.
So this is the 17th century.
I mean,
this isn't sort of scuba diving now off,
you know,
the,
the great barrier reef or something like that.
I mean,
so what they're doing is they're reclaiming the land from the sea.
Uh,
now what this has to do with global economy is that you have to be able to feed
the population.
And so they have,
along with the English,
and these two facts are related and agricultural revolution.
They have an agricultural revolution,
uh,
investment and commercialized agriculture and increase in the poppy,
in,
in production,
in rural areas.
And in the case of the Netherlands,
it's because of this,
I'll talk about why it happened in Britain another time.
It's because they reclaim land.
How much land did they reclaim from the sea?
Well,
36,000 acres,
just between 50,
90,
and 1615.
So that's a phenomenal amount and they keep going over and over again.
And so the population of the Dutch republic increases between 15,
50 and 16.
52,
almost 2 million people.
And this is in a pretty small,
I mean,
it's bigger than Belgium,
but it's,
this is a pretty small,
uh,
a territory.
Um,
and so Amsterdam,
um,
by mid,
uh,
by mid 17th century,
by 1650,
uh,
increases to 150,000,
people.
So they build these three large canals.
And this,
this expands,
uh,
the,
the area of the city by four times.
And what this means is that the,
that,
that merchants,
uh,
that boats can dock outside these kind of big warehouses and can unload or,
it depending on the case,
uh,
load,
goods.
Um,
and so,
uh,
you have 500 miles of canals dug just in the middle decades of the 17th century.
So it becomes a sort of economic dynamo.
Uh,
uh,
because of that,
and in Dutch traders are to be found everywhere in the 1630 or 2,500 trading
ships.
Uh,
and,
uh,
they become the principal supplier of grain and fish,
in,
in Europe.
And the Dutch,
uh,
dominate the Baltic,
a Baltic,
uh,
trade.
I mean,
cities like Gdansk,
which we tend to forget about unfortunately,
which is a very important,
uh,
port,
then,
and still now it's worse.
Solidarity began to,
as many of you know,
in,
in 1980,
uh,
is an important,
important port,
uh,
in all of this.
And,
and they reached the West indies are the east indies and the 1620s in the 1630.
So they bring back to cinema,
nutmeg and,
and all sorts of,
uh,
in all sorts of valuables.
And it's this kind of wealth that allow them to fight this long,
hard war of independence,
which they finally,
they finally win.
Now why is this in here?
Now?
This is Rembrandt is most of,
you know,
this is,
uh,
this is called the nightwatch.
Um,
and the importance of this painting is who's being painted.
And more than that,
who is,
is getting Rembrandt to paint this.
And you know,
if you go down into France,
if you,
if you go to,
uh,
my bed phones,
if you go to,
to there,
I mean,
but the painting is dominated by nobles who want pictures of themselves,
uh,
or the,
you know,
the,
uh,
tiresome Sun King,
and all that sort of,
you know,
miserable hangers on a very rich,
miserable hangers on.
And what,
who'd love to ditch Dutch painted what Dutch painters painted?
I reflects in the same way that renaissance art reflected,
you know,
what,
what was important to renaissance Italy?
Uh,
who did the commissioning of painting?
I care about it.
My mother was a painter.
She was a portrait painter.
That's how we,
that's how we survive,
uh,
in Portland,
Oregon.
Um,
uh,
what,
who commissioned these paintings and what they,
what they painted tell you who these people thought they were.
So that's pretty interesting.
So who are these?
This is the night watch.
These are the guys who run Amsterdam.
Uh,
these,
this is a,
essentially the,
the town,
the town hall,
uh,
of Amsterdam.
Uh,
and in fact that building itself,
which I don't have a slide in it,
you know,
it's extremely modest.
It looks so terribly different than,
than,
than anything.
Uh,
the Spanish palace outside of Madrid or,
or,
or anything that ever heading do with the,
the,
uh,
Prussian kings are,
and all that.
Well,
it's pretty obvious.
Um,
so this is,
this is the way in a house,
and here,
this is very classic.
I'm not a professor of architecture,
but it's obvious.
This is northern European architecture that you can see in northern France that
he's like a Haas and other places are Sharvin admins the area.
And they all is one of the most fabulous pluses anywhere or in the plastic
voltage,
which is by far the most beautiful plus in Paris.
Uh,
you have this,
this kind of architecture,
but this is the weighing house there.
And so,
I mean the buildings,
and here's another one.
Uh,
and so the buildings are the most important.
Buildings in the cities are not huge or over the top rope churches,
a sentence of Jay Zoo in Rome for example,
they are weighing houses.
They are things that,
uh,
and the town hall is a very modest proportions.
And,
and because it's Calvinist,
I mean,
Calvinists were an exactly,
uh,
it was French called Rigo,
no word.
Exactly.
You know,
wild,
fun,
loving types.
Uh,
you know,
the,
even the churches are completely denuded of,
of the kinds of baroque swooning,
cherubs and clutter that,
that you found in,
in beautiful,
I'm not knocking the broke,
but beautiful churches or in building [inaudible] in Vienna is a good example of
that.
Or anywhere is a good example of that.
My God.
Um,
and here's another weighing house.
This is in Gouda as in the cheese,
but the town of Gouda to Amsterdam wasn't alum.
Now here,
these are houses that were built along the canals.
And so you've got these warehouses along the canals.
And here's where the bankers,
the Dutch had the most along with the English,
uh,
the most sophisticated banking system in the world.
Uh,
uh,
the Lloyd's of London,
which now does things like,
you know,
uh,
ensure quarterbacks knees and things.
Uh,
but it begins in the 18th century.
when people go into the docs and say,
look,
we want to,
cause a lot of these ships go blob on the way back,
or are taken by by pirates and stuff like that and said,
well,
we want to ensure the ship.
Will you sign up for 10% of the value of this insurance?
And that's how Lloyd's of London starts.
But to have the same thing in,
in the equivalent in Amsterdam as well.
And you've got that,
you have access to capital by these guys.
Those guys,
they're no longer there.
The middleclass guys behind the,
behind the screen,
uh,
who are going to invest in these long,
you know,
tracks.
You send off a ship to Newfoundland or to Iceland or,
or,
or even into the Mediterranean,
they start getting into the Mediterranean.
And that scares the hell out of,
uh,
out of the other commercial rivals.
So,
but you build these also houses for people to live in.
And because there's not a lot of room between the canals,
that's why they're so steep when you walk up these things.
I mean,
it's really,
it's almost like that it says,
be inclined and they seem to be reaching toward the sky there,
but not reaching towards the sky as in,
uh,
you know,
it's in the cupola of a Baroque church.
We were supposed to see God at the top here.
They're trying to,
they look up and they see money at the top or whatever.
But,
but,
uh,
I mean,
they were religious.
It's well,
but it was a different kind of,
of religion.
And,
and here,
uh,
this is a,
you know,
a more modern example.
And with a little,
a little,
uh,
you know,
Hash cafe next to it or something.
But this is Rembrandt's house.
Uh,
uh,
and you know,
he had to lose some somewhere and that's where he lived because he paints these
people.
And Rembrandt did have one time where you started painting kind of Catholic
themes,
but basically he's like these other guys,
uh,
they're painting,
well I'll tell you in a minute,
but they're painting middleclass life in the Netherlands.
Uh,
and they don't do big battle scenes.
You have to go to the southern Netherlands or Belgium for that or into France.
Uh,
so that's,
that's what they do.
Uh,
and that's,
that's what,
that's what they look like.
That's pretty obvious.
Um,
this is,
uh,
an orphanage they had without question the most sophisticated charitable
institutions anywhere.
In fact,
we know what they ate there.
Ma,
it was the most prosperous country for ordinary people anywhere.
The Diet here,
we know what they ate in their meals.
They ate much better than,
than,
uh,
than poor people did almost anywhere else.
Indeed,
some ordinary workers bought paintings,
uh,
by,
Steen and all sorts of these other,
these other people.
Uh,
and here is,
uh,
a work house.
This is a,
is a prison basically.
Uh,
they were organized for that too.
Now one shouldn't,
Eh,
you know,
it was the place of tolerance.
There's of toleration,
there's no doubt about that.
And during the enlightenment,
lots of the enlightenment,
uh,
the work,
the philosophic that could not be published in France were published in
Switzerland more about that another time.
And in the Netherlands,
but they could lash out.
They lashed out at gay.
Sometimes they lashed out at Catholic sometimes,
uh,
you know,
they,
there was an edge to them as if the whole thing could collapse on their heads.
This is Simon Schama is not the only person who'd made that point.
Others have as well pref because of the cause of the big floods.
If the dike goes,
here's the image of the Dutch boy with his finger in the dyke,
if the dike goes,
you are drowned.
Uh,
and there's this whole sense that,
that,
that the thing is precarious.
And you better kind of mind your mind,
your p's and q's or whatever the expression is.
Uh,
and,
and act for a good,
very beat,
be a good person or this whole thing could kind of be literally flooded away.
That whole different.
That is then this modest estate of y'all,
cy,
I've worked in the archives and just sigh in the smallest stables.
Uh,
you know,
this is one of my least favorite,
uh,
a palaces,
but it's just,
I mean,
the way the Dutch thought about the settles,
there's a little different than the way that the French nobility or the Spanish
renewables,
at least at the higher ranks thought about themselves as well.
And I show these,
these are obvious,
but just to put them in comparison with which we'll see in the middle,
a little modest bedroom,
they're in Versailles,
uh,
while this is,
this is,
uh,
the war room is called a [inaudible] settle the gang.
Uh,
and I don't like just say what the hell.
And this is Volfi columns,
which is much more interesting.
I just put this in because I like it.
But it shows you,
you know,
there are shot toes in,
there were chateaus in the Netherlands,
but they were mostly in the east.
There were nobles had the Chateau and,
and they didn't dominate.
They didn't rule.
Uh,
uh,
this vote of he called was,
it was fabulous.
And Louie the 14th was invited by his treasurer,
a man called foodK to go and eat there.
And he was insanely jealous.
Uh,
and they served him on,
uh,
on gold plates with gold silverware.
And he had huge pond stocked with not only fresh water fish,
but saltwater fish.
And he was so jealous,
jealous that he threw him in the slam air,
threw him in jail and confiscated it.
But,
but the,
the,
the image,
it's just that this is very different.
And the paintings you found there were very different.
Here's Rembrandt himself.
Can we,
can you,
can you cut the light a little bit?
You know how to do that.
I'm,
there's somewhere,
there's a missing thing here.
It might be missing.
Thing might be in my head.
I don't know.
But where the hell you do this thing?
Does anyone there know I'm going,
I don't know.
But,
uh,
thanks.
That was Rembrandt.
That was quick.
But here's what,
just,
here's here.
He's still there.
He,
he did about narcissism.
He did something like 70 self portraits.
He was his own favorite,
a a subject.
But Anyway,
um,
uh,
my mother tried to paint me but I never held still long enough.
And so there's only sort of two half of finished portraits of me.
But anyway,
what did people paint roosdale this,
don't write this down,
but what you can if you want,
but go to the great museum in Amsterdam and see if the Rex Museum Rosedale
painted,
you know,
ordinary people living a and a at work.
Uh,
uh,
and this is the,
this is,
these are windmills obviously.
Um,
and hear windmills with people the same thing.
But this is,
if you wouldn't find these sorts of generally these,
these kinds of paintings in,
in,
in other places.
This is a painter called phones house,
h a.
L.
S.
Uh,
it's a family scene.
These are middle class people having paintings,
commissioning paintings of themselves.
You know,
it's the equivalent of,
of sort of fancy patricians in,
in Florence having paintings of themselves,
but they're from a very different social class is the patricians and Florence
were or Venice.
Uh,
and so it's just,
this is sort of the sets of same,
I love still lives,
especially if they have food and wine.
And this is how this is,
there's some wine up there and this is a batter class.
Uh,
probably mispronounce Cla as c.
and this is still life.
They paint food,
they fade,
paint,
food and people eating and people having fun,
not people at war.
Uh,
and not,
uh,
people,
not that those services to 18th century paintings of the inevitable paintings of
the British nobles or land,
Big Gentry,
uh,
looking over the,
all of the villages they've had knocked down so they could expand their hunting
a terrain or,
or,
or funneling the nose of their killer hunting dogs or something like that.
It's just a very different way of imagining oneself.
And I mean,
it's very attractive.
I must find that very,
very attractive.
This is the village school.
They had the highest literacy rate in the world period.
Uh,
the Dutch did a very,
very ordinary people and there were poor people in the Netherlands.
Nonetheless,
we're very ordinary,
uh,
literate poor people.
And there's something to be said for that.
And I like cats a lot.
I hate dogs.
But anyways,
so this is just a,
you know,
children playing with a cat.
My cat yesterday actually undid my password last night of I Yale Password.
I saw the thing I said it said Password and next I knew she had literally typed
it really dedicated my password.
I put a new one.
There's nothing to do with anyone so should take this out.
But anyway,
uh,
cat,
there I go.
Or boom,
this is what we do in the south of France was a little Sheldon in Yakutia we
put,
we play boule the,
you know,
you don't,
it's not quite the same thing.
That's like bace we have this sort of metal ball and that's another for another
lecture.
But anyway,
uh,
you don't have a lot of that.
Uh,
but see these are ordinary people having fun.
Here they are.
Here they are having fun.
Yeah.
But see there they're having too much fun and this is part of the point because
part of this certain veteran Calvinism and part of the kind of fact that that
what if the dams burst or what if the British begin to outdo us in the World
Trade Department or what if the French come and squish us like grapes.
There's always this sense of vulnerability and behind the paintings of people
eating the theme of people eating or praying prayers at mealtime and this sort
of thing or playing boon,
you know,
pay Tom Bochy.
There's always this sense of the rivaled family.
That's what this is called by stain.
S.
T.
E.
N that,
uh,
that if you have too much fun things,
we'll get away from you.
And these people are all,
all,
all drinking and leaving these poor little children to their own device.
And they may be knocking down one or two of themselves there because nobody's
paying any attention.
You could go too far and then you end up like this.
And then how does it all end up in the long run?
Well,
how it ends up in the long run for the Dutch is that the Dutch cease to be a
great power,
but there's nothing wrong with that.
They'll go on to live highly prosperous lives.
Uh,
they eventually end up with a monarchy.
they eventually lose Belgium in 1831.
Uh,
they basically,
I didn't care,
uh,
the Dutch economy rather than the equivalent would be the Venetians of the
decline of the Venetian,
uh,
economic power in the Mediterranean,
in,
in try a trade with,
uh,
with the east.
Uh,
it diminishes,
uh,
the Netherlands a thesis to be a great power,
whereas England,
uh,
becomes in Britain has,
it becomes in 1707 becomes a,
the biggest of the world powers.
But let us still remember these six factors are seven,
her many I had up there.
And remember what these two places had in common.
It has a lot to do with the global trade,
has a lot to do with social structure,
has a lot to do with,
with who they thought they were,
the paintings they bought,
the paintings they commissioned,
the way they viewed themselves.
Uh,
and part of this re constructing of national identity often has as much to do
with who you're not,
not absolute,
not Catholic,
not French as it does with,
you know,
with who you imagine yourself to be.
And in the growth of,
of national awareness,
that itself is an important theme.
Have a great weekend.
See you on Monday.